شفا عمر 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم بسرعه
من غير تفكير كيفك انت شفت من الطبخ هو
مهنتك
انه انا بحب هذا الشيء كثير من كل قلبي
اكثر شيء يميز كشف
كثير ودخلت النكتب الطبخ يعني كنت على
طبيعتي تماما هذا الاختلاف عن اي شيء ثاني
هل تشعر بالضغط انك لازم تاخذ موقف سياسي
من الاحداث في بلدك سوريا
ااا
هلا هذا طبعا اكيد يعني بيعطيني شعور
بالضغط بخصوص هذا الموضوع اا لكن انا
بالنهايه طباخ فقط يعني هذا الشيء شخصي
هذا شيء انا حرفيا يعني شخصي بالنسبه لي
اوكي مين اشطر في الطبخه انت او زوجتك
الاحراج انا طبعا باعتراف
[موسيقى]
له علاقه مثلا بشيء من العنصريه او هذه
المواضيع ابدا او توجه لي كلام من حدا
الحمد لله لحد الان ابدا طيب ممتاز لما
بتخفي ليش بتخفي زوجتك وما بتظهرها معك
هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]
هي حره فيه يعني فيه انا ما عندي مشكله
حابه تطلع بس هي ما بدك
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
تشوف نفسك بعد عشر سنوات جديد
مين اكثر شاف بيلفتك محتواه وبيتابعه على
يوتيوب
متى سيعود الشيف عمر من تركيا ويستقر في
العالم العربي
قريبا قريبا جدا
3 ملايين بتفوق الربع مليون دولار سنويا
بس تدور عليهم
مره صحيح هذا الكلام
غلط
100%
اقل من ربع مليون سنه
[موسيقى]
يعني 200 ايي 240 مثلا 23
[ضحك]
اكله انت فاشل فيها الصراحه
[موسيقى]
الكلمات
ايه طبعا يعني الحقيقه
النساء ممكن عندهم صبر الاكل بده صبر يعني
غير المحبه وغير كثير شغلات بده صبر اكيد
اكل امهات
لكن الصبر انا عم بحكي عن موضوع الصبر
اوكي
كان مكتوب عليها انه اسم زي اسم يعني
انا اذا بعدها بلدي ما حدا قال له عندي
يعني الوقت بدي ارجع على بلدي برجع بالوقت
لي انا بدي اياه وما حدا بيمنعني طبعا طيب
فقط كثير من وزنك ايش السر
من بعد ما طلعت من كيتو دايت لحد الان
ثلاث سنين ممنوع سكره ابيض الا طبعا
بالتصوير هيك اما بس شاي والقهوه والصفر
طيب شخصيه
شهيرهم عندك في المطبخ
[موسيقى]
همم ايمن رضا
انا مثله طبعا يعني
وكثير بحبه تواصل انا واياه على طول نحكي
تليفونات مع بعض وهو متابعني وانا طبعا
اكيد يعني متابعه وفي فكره يعني يوم من
الايام اكيد نعمل شيء مع بعض طيب اوصف
بنتك لونا وبنتك في كلمه
العشق العشق
في المطبخ العربي ومن هنا بدات تغيير ما
تحس انك بلغت في وصف نفسك يعني وتاثيرك
كشف
هون في نقطه في انسان مثلا انه عم يعمل
شيء كثير كبير من حاله انه انا هيك وانا
هيك لا انا ما اقصد بهيج جمله بضبط
شايف عمر هو اول مين دخل همم النكته
والمسحه لقلب الاكل قبل ما كانت موجوده
يعني اي حدا بتشوفيه اليوم عم بيمزح وعم
بيساوي اكل هذا بعد
التلفزيون
يعني مثلا حسن او عفوا حسين الامام لما
كان بيطلع مع عمرو اديب وبيطبخ كان دائما
بينكت وبيعلق عمرو اديب هو اللي كان يمزح
وحتى حسين كان يخليه يعني هو يجره على
المزح اما الشيف دائما بيشوفوا انه سيف ذو
حدين بيخاف بقول لك انه انا عم بشتغل
بالاكل وامزح الموضوع مرعب مع انه ممكن
يكون شخصيه جدا على الواقع لكن بيشوف
الموضوع بيخوف بالنسبه له انا اساسا لما
طلعت من الاصطناع لما تحولت يعني خلص انه
رجعت على طبيعتي بدي اعمل الكاميرا يوتيوب
يوتيوب
منصات السوشيال ميديا بشكل عام
واحد من الانتقادات ضدك انك تحكي كثير في
فيديوهاتك انا ما بحكي كثير اليوم في عندك
كم هائل من المعلومات انا دائما بحط حالي
محل الانسان الي عم بيتفرج علي بده ياخذ
الوصفه في امور بسيطه الشيف يعني باقي
شايفين
انا بسيطه لكن الناس اللي بتتفرج ما بتعرف
لازم اشرح كلها بفيديو ما يكون طويل وما
يكون ممل بشكل سريع جدا فانا مضطر احكي
بهذا الشكل انا بالفيديو ما بحكي بسرعه
لكن لما بيصير في مونتاج وقطع الكلام كله
متوصل مع بعضه بالعكس الناس يعني انا لازم
بالنهائي وصل المعلومه الناس
مسلسل سوري
امم اوكي بس ما انت معارض فكره التمثيل
اذا شيء ذوقيني
مسلسل بقدم ايمي للمجتمع طيب من واحد
لعشره قديش انت عصبي
اكثر طلب بيطلبوه منك متابعينك
[ضحك]
طيب
مصفى في الشفه الناجح
يكون متواضع
كشف اصدقاء
[موسيقى]
يعني يكون في علم وراء هذا الشيء اللي عم
يشتغل ويكون في عنده نفس ومحبه بتشيل عم
بيعملوا هذول الشغل
بعد بعد المليون ولا بعد 100 مليون
طبعا اكيد